jussie ya ce garçon que vous présentez
qui s'appelle quentin qu'on a découvert
qu'il était devant le studio avant qu'on
arrive et on l'a entendu tu fais du
steel drum ça et j'ai entendu dire que
tu avais l'oreille musicale
ton père qui m'a dit ça il a derrière
moi qui m'a dit que ton père avait dit
ça sur les percus s'est passé c'est pas
vraiment ça c'est entendent les notes tu
suis pas je pas l'oreille absolue mais
c'est henri d'accord alors là tu vas
nous faire un truc on va faire un blind
test très rapide on joue également chez
bhl est ce que tu peux nous faire déjà
un premier titre on va tout une marque
de quoi il s'agit vas-y fais-le 28-28
passé pour toi là c'est pour eux c'est
pour qu'ils cessent pas pour quelle
liste
[Musique]
avec nous demain pour la spéciale saint
valentin
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
on dirait que tu arrives au club la
bouche d'un coup tactique peut nous
faire le truc pour kenny alors écoutez
écoutez les mettre la musique avec faut
les mettre la musique folk avallon
frappa le vannetais nous travaillons sol
cabanes faites un beau duo tous les
arbres statues à quel âge tu as 15 ans à
15 ans c'est dingue et tu as déjà plus
grand que j'ai dit allez on y va quand
on a dit m
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
oh
[Musique]
à
t
elle a mangé délais
[Musique]
oh
je suis content
je
avoir lu au style drame et voilà on a eu
un coup de coeur pour toi tu as fait
c'est cette date et de la télé direct on
fait juste que je demande un service
avant tullaye aucun d'un est-ce qu'on
peut récupérer ça pour un plat à tajine
pobeda il